don't [ __ ] not in my face stupid the
[ __ ] not on me stupid like like I
dropped the soul right right right right
right so I dropped the soap right listen
listen listen listen listen ain't nobody
gonna [ __ ] me in ass right that's what I
thought
listen listen listen okay they did you
know [ __ ] no that's the name of this
episode don't [ __ ] not on me stupid
oh my god that boy is he's in general
pop dude he's going away the [ __ ] going
away he's in general population are you
saying they're gonna treat him like a
starburst they're gonna unwrap him chew
him up they're gonna really turn him
into a skittle it's crazy yeah man
that's crazy yeah imagine like doing all
I do i oh I look I look and then you get
to jail in your life uh-uh uh-uh no more
ah man it's all I think about is the
amount of [ __ ] that he's talked in his
life like the amount of [ __ ] like you
spent the last year talking [ __ ] to
everybody
mm-hmm everybody that hates you is
sitting there just being like with a
giant smile on their face yeah he's
gonna you don't know we're talking about
six nine just got convicted arrested
yesterday
yeah and he's most unlike five six six
felonies two of which hold a minimum
like or a minimum sentence of twenty
five and a max of life sentence in
prison and the judge will probably not
rule them concurrent because you can get
like six counts of something but it's
like to be served concurrently okay so
it's like you only do whatever that's
[ __ ] crazy think I'll get out of this
[ __ ] no they've dude the Fed is a
conviction rate of 90% what's he gonna
do he has to snitch yes - yeah yeah if
he gets out he snitched I was reading
that people were speculating like the
best he could do is take a plea deal
and do like four to seven years
basically snitch on everybody and do
like a quarter quarter of the sentence
man I would just do that I mean he's
gonna tell I guarantee you he snitches
you think so yeah I mean still you get
out in five to seven years nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you anymore
nobody i'm bobby shmurda i mean bobby
schmurder like he's gonna have a hard
time coming back I don't think so
like he sees style is like a little bit
old school now oh okay so I think his
first record will blow yeah but yeah
Kevin gates went away and he's having a
hard time yeah well brands yes fans but
he's not was number one like he went he
went platinum on his album with no
features yeah his first album like the
phone's one that's what I mean yeah he
came back and no people listen to a [ __ ]
but it's not he's not like Kevin gates
Kevin gates I wonder what he's feeling
like right now like you he's on top of
the [ __ ] world he's on top of the
world now he's on top of that dick of
the FBI I was on the out of either war
do you go into prison with pigtails
you're a girl homie and he's built like
a girl he's like five foot three
yeah he's flat-chested he walked in
there like a little Spanish he's got six
nine tattooed on his [ __ ] forehead
dude they're gonna make him say he
walked in there like a little [ __ ]
Spanish keira knightley mm-hmm let just
what justice [ __ ] well little [ __ ]
Queen Amidala yeah yeah that's not the
same actor yeah that's Natalie Portman
yeah yeah
what's Keira Knightley been in parts of
the Caribbean yeah yeah yeah yeah there
you go
that's so funny dude all them pirates in
there gonna have tons of pirate sex with
a little jail with rainbow pigtails and
a 69 tattooed all over your body
and you're going down the cell block and
they oh wait you 6-9 6-9 me first I want
to sixth not me
Oh only gonna be six though yeah you
know I'm saying there's no it's gonna be
no nine part of that yeah it's just
gonna be six it's gonna be him [ __ ]
with this little boy [ __ ] there's no
prison dude would suck a dude's dick at
the same time as getting his dick sucked
no but they're just gonna like tuck six
9s balls up and just smush his cheeks
together so you're saying he's gonna eat
his ass wall yeah six nine second is
that even is that's just the bottom of
the cheeks like he's just gonna make it
like I'm a makeshift vagina he's just
gonna push them together
yeah like feel like a vagina cuz six
nines got everything but the vagina it's
so demeaning no it is I can't I really
hope no one hears this yeah from Trey
way yes yeah yeah just kidding I'm sorry
kidding this comedian sorry just kidding
it's just crazy dude crazy why you
[ __ ] selling drugs
dude it's more than that it's selling
drugs it's like firearms it's yeah well
it's funny is I had a man's name on
Twitter they're making fun of like the
racketeering charge these dudes on
Twitter just going off like in that
fight for mobsters yeah it is right yeah
I guess it's like a blanket catch-all
like law okay that that racketeering a
lot of [ __ ] falls under racketeering I
thought I was like making counterfeit
badminton rackets yeah so I wasn't like
doing them on a black mark yeah I wasn't
gonna do it but I just [ __ ] did it
yeah whatever whatever six 9s selling
[ __ ] opium laced rackets to roger
federer racketeering oh dude he's going
away someone was like kids think it's
like four album promo oh yeah poor poor
kids well you don't go to the Fed for
album promo literally it's on their
website it's an official page yeah of
all the charges yeah you know it's crazy
those like he's gonna martin shkreli's
gonna do less time you think sounds 6:9
like yeah they're gonna make an example
of 6-9 that's so crazy cold that's just
the end of your life mmm
yeah probably have everything in front
of him Oh [ __ ] album dropping on
Friday had everything so insane dude why
are you doing crime if you're rich you
know what's crazy he [ __ ] in the in
the thing and like the article it says
he had a million and a half in his bank
account which like if your if your fee
is a hunter cape or show it should be
higher should be way higher than that of
a hidden EMP taxes yet he's been doing
this for a year he spent all his money
first yeah what on [ __ ] you must have
spent a million bucks on designer
clothes like [ __ ] he expenses
[ __ ] yeah all that a million a half
grand scheme of things isn't that much
acting like he's a pop star yeah not
even close would don't even close
oh my god dude maybe he doesn't care
that he's going away you don't think so
maybe he just like spent it all I was
like [ __ ] I might as well go to jail
yeah yeah no he cares yeah definitely
[Music]
these are got some fun
[Music]